nielsen
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión de los observadores de france 24
esta semana vamos a comenzar en líbano
donde el país vídeo una crisis social
política y económica desde hace más de
18 meses en este contexto algunos
jóvenes activistas libaneses denuncian
algunos supermercados que dicen que se
están aprovechando de esta situación
[Música]
esta pelea entre dos clientes estalló
por la última bolsa fórmula para bebé
que quedaba en los estantes de este
supermercado de virus debut desde 2019
el líbano se enfrenta a una crisis
económica sin precedentes con una
inflación disparada que ha llevado a uno
de cada dos niveles a estar por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza por lo que las
escenas de forcejeo se han multiplicado
en supermercados
en frente a las panaderías
para ayudar a los hogares a hacer frente
al elevado costo de la vida el gobierno
libanés creó subsidios para productos
básicos como el arroz la pasta y el
aceite pero somos muchos activistas
libaneses los comerciantes deshonestos
no dudan en engañar esconder los
productos subsidiados en las bodegas
para favorecer la venta de los productos
no subsidiados que son vendidos a un
precio mucho mayor nosotros haremos
periodista y activista acompañó a grupos
de activistas que entraron a varios
supermercados para inspeccionar los y te
llevan a los supermercados revisaban los
están donde se supone que están
exhibidos los productos subsidiados
cuando no hay cantidades suficientes en
amablemente al encargado
porque si productos oxidados hay que
ponerlos en los estantes
voy a decirles otras cosas algunos por
mercados no duran en sacar los productos
subsidiados de sus empaques donde se ve
la marca
sacan ese producto y lo ponen en el
paquete diferente para que parezca que
no está subsidiado por ejemplo su
producto que se vende a un precio
subsidiado de 2000 libras libanesas lo
venden en otro paquete de 10 mil libras
leonesas
se pueden encontrar decenas de paquetes
en las calles desechados al lado de un
supermercado a veces un poco alejados
para no levantar sospechas
[Aplausos]
hasta entonces el estado realizado pocas
inspecciones en los supermercados
los manifestantes los activistas y los
periodistas son los que sacaron a
relucir este problema reemplazaron al
estado y ahora el ministerio de economía
ha reforzado las inspecciones ordenadas
y envía cada vez más inspectores a los
mercados
nosotros como periodistas y activistas
seguiremos dándole más al pueblo web
dejando lamentado ya la cuestión de si
seguiremos cubriendo estas iniciativas
en directo a través de internet lo
acusan dejando al lado y denunciando la
corrupción dondequiera que se dan
ahora hablemos de un nuevo reto en la
red social tick tock jóvenes se graban
desempacando paquetes que contienen
animales vivos una práctica que preocupa
a la fundación 30 millones y amigos que
denuncia la tendencia de nuestra
sociedad de mercantilizar a los animales
soy la presidenta de la fundación 30
millones de amigos uno creería que esta
niña que recibe este paquete por correo
va a desempacar un par de zapatos pero
no lo que hay es un ser vivo y sensible
en el paquete y obviamente no tiene idea
de cómo cuidarlo
así que eso es lo que realmente impactó
a los internautas cuchillos este aspecto
del animal objetos y animal animal de
moda
no tengo palabras desde cuándo se puede
comprar un ser vivo en internet como si
se comprara un par de jeans imagínense
el estrés es algo traumático para estos
animales son seres vivos en el 2015 de
la fundación 30 millones de amigos logró
hacer que el código civil es decir la
base del derecho francés reconociera a
los animales como seres vivos y
sensibles
en italia este animal en vez de ir a
comprar un animal en un almacén en una
tienda de animales es mejor ir a un
criadero serio y hablar con la persona
que les dará este animal
donis este animal con 30 millones de
amigos cuenta con más de 250 refugios en
francia
para perros gatos pero también para
animales exóticos rising masters lo más
humano
este ir a estos refugios y adoptar
animales desde niño
pero por más increíble que esto parezca
esta es una práctica legal y como una en
francia pero se tiene que contratar a un
transportista especializado para
minimizar los riesgos y el maltrato
animal
y esta manera llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana recuerde
que siempre esperamos sus fotos y vídeos
aficionados para contar la historia del
lado de la gente y por supuesto nuestros
contactos aparecen en pantalla hasta una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]